LET'S BRING MAGGIE HABERMAN FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
YOU'VE COVERED DONALD TRUMP AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN, AS PRESIDENT
AND NOW POST-PRESIDENCY.
LETITIA JAMES ESSENTIALLY SAID
THE WHOLE THING WAS A SCAM AND
THE WHOLE THING HE VALUES MOST,
ALL THOSE BUILDINGS, ALL THOSE
GOLF COURSES, ALL THOSE ENTITIES
THAT HAVE THE TRUMP NAME USUALLY
IN BIG GOLD LETTERS ON THEM.
>> RIGHT, JOHN.
IT WAS A REALLY SWEEPING, I
DON'T WANT TO USE THE WORD
INDICTMENT BECAUSE THAT'S A
LEGAL TERM BUT IT WAS A
CONDEMNATION OF DONALD TRUMP'S
BUSINESS PRACTICES OVER A VERY
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
REMEMBER, HE DIDN'T JUST START
ENGAGING IN THESE PRACTICES OVER
THE PERIOD OF TIME SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, HE'S BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR A LONG TIME.
I THINK A KEY POINT OF WHAT SHE
IS SAYING HERE, JOHN, IS THERE
WERE TANGIBLE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
COULD SEE THAT LOOKED REAL.
HE'S SAYING THAT HE JUST
MASSIVELY INFLATED THE VALUE TO
TURN THEM INTO SOMETHING ELSE AS
HE WAS DEALING WITH LENDERS OR
BANKS AND SO FORTH.
THIS IS GOING TO DRAG OUT FOR A
WHILE, JOHN.
THIS IS A CIVIL SUIT.
SHE IS MAKING A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL, I BELIEVE, AND IT'S UP
TO OTHERS TO DECIDE WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO WITH THIS.
THERE WAS A QUESTION AT THE
PRESS CONFERENCE THAT THE IRS
HAD ACCESS TO THE SAME
INFORMATION AND HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING.
WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES.
BUT THE CIVIL PENALTY HERE THAT
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT IMPOSING,
THE DOLLARS ARE MASSIVE.
AND WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT AS
A POTENTIAL IMPACT OF TAKING
AWAY THEIR BUSINESS CERTIFICATES
IS MASSIVE AS WELL.
>> AND SHE'S ESSENTIALLY SAYING
SHE WANTS TO RESTRICT, HAMSTRING
HIS ABILITY, THE FAMILY'S
ABILITY TO DO ANYTHING WITH
THOSE PROPERTIES, ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN NEW YORK STATE, UNTIL
THIS IS RESOLVED, WHICH IS A
GIANT STRAITJACKET AROUND THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY ARE STUCK NOW.
HE HAS MOVED TO FLORIDA, HIS
CHILDREN HAVE MOVED TO FLORIDA.
HE HAS MOVED A BUNCH OF HIS
OPERATIONS DOWN THERE.
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION IS STILL
LOCATED AT TRUMP TOWER.
THIS REALLY PRECLUDES HIM FROM
ANYTHING OR IS HOPING TO
PRECLUDE HIM FROM ANYTHING ELSE
HE MIGHT TRY TO DO AND KEEPS HIM
STILL AND IN PLACE AND KEEPS HIM
FROM DOING ADDITIONAL DEALS.
JOHN, REALISTICALLY, I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY ADDITIONAL DEALS
WERE AVAILABLE TO DONALD TRUMP
IN NEW YORK WHERE HE'S A FAIRLY
UNPOPULAR FIGURE IN MANY PLACES
AND HE ALWAYS STRUGGLED IN TERMS
OF BANKS LENDING TO HIM.
BUT I THINK THIS MAKES IT HARDER
FOR HIM TO MOVE OUTSIDE OF NEW
YORK.
>> YOU KNOW HIM BETTER THAN
MOST.
YOU JUST WROTE A GREAT BOOK
ABOUT HIM.
HOW DOES DONALD TRUMP TAKE THIS
NEWS?
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
INVESTIGATIONS OF DONALD TRUMP,
HE CALLS THEM WITCH HUNTS.
THIS GOES THROUGH NEARLY 300
PAGES THROUGH HIS TRUMP
ORGANIZATION AND SAYS HE'S A
LIAR, HE'S A CHEAT AND WORSE.
HOW DOES HE TAKE THIS?
>> NOT HAPPILY, JOHN.
DONALD TRUMP HAS SPENT DECADES
TRYING TO BUILD UP THIS IMAGE AS
A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSMAN AND HAS
TRIED TO PREVENT ANY EFFORT TO
SUGGEST OTHERWISE.
TIM O'BRIEN OF BLOOMBERG, YOU
KNOW, WROTE A BOOK IN WHICH HE
TALKED ABOUT THIS AND DONALD
TRUMP SUED HIM AND LOST OVER HIS
CLAIMS.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HE HAS
TRIED TO BAT AWAY FOR SOME TIME.
THERE ARE MANY INVESTIGATIONS
INTO HIM.
ON THE ONE HAND I HEARD SOME
RELIEF FROM PEOPLE AROUND TRUMP
THAT THERE'S NO CRIMINAL CHARGE
INVOLVED RIGHT HERE RELATED TO
THIS, ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT CLEAR TO
ME HOW MUCH JURISDICTION JAMES
WOULD HAVE OVER THAT.
BUT THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
GOES TO TRUMP'S SELF-IMAGE AND
TRUMP'S PROJECTED IMAGE AND THIS
ONE IS GOING TO STING IN WAYS
THAT INVESTIGATIONS RELATED TO
HIS PRESIDENCY DON'T BOTHER HIM
AS MUCH.
>> MAGGIE HABERMAN, APPRECIATE
THE VALUABLE INSIGHTS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS WITH OUR
REPORTERS AND LEGAL ANALYSTS.
DANA BASH, JEREMY DIAMOND, TIA
MITCHELL.
SHAN WU.
LET ME START WITH YOU.
THIS IS A CIVIL CASE BUT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYS SHE IS
ESSENTIALLY GOING TO MAKE
CRIMINAL REFERRALS OR SEND
THINGS TO THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK AND THE INTERNAL
REVENUE SERVICE.
SHE IS ALLEGING THAT SHE ALSO
HAS THE EVIDENCE OF CRIMES.
>> RIGHT.
AND SO THE EVIDENCE THAT SHE HAS
AMASSED FOR THIS SUIT, WHICH WAS
VERY HARD FOUGHT TO GET IT AFTER
A LOT OF LITIGATION WOULD
PROVIDE THE BASIS FOR THOSE
CRIMINAL ACTIONS, TAX FRAUD.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S TAX FRAUD
GOING ON GIVEN THE MASSIVE
INFLATION OF THESE VALUES.
AND SAME THING FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT.
SO SHE'S GIVING THEM A VERY
VALUABLE HEAD START ON ALL THIS
EVIDENCE THEY HAVE TAKEN SO LONG
TO GATHER.
THAT'S WHAT REALLY STRIKES ME
ABOUT THIS COMPLAINT IS HOW WELL
DOCUMENTED THIS IS.
THERE ARE FACTS YOU CAN'T SPIN
YOUR WAY OUT OF.
CLAIMING THAT THE PENTHOUSE, FOR
EXAMPLE, IS THREE TIMES THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE THAT IT IS,
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU CAN SPIN
YOUR WAY OUT OF THAT.
>> SQUARE FOOTAGE IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN MEASURE.
HE SAYS IT WAS 33,000 SQUARE
FEET AND SHE SAYS IT IS 11,000.
JUST ON THE IDEA OF HOW THIS
PROCEEDS, DONALD TRUMP CAN
DELAY, CAN DELAY, CAN DELAY.
IN TERMS OF A CIVIL SUIT LIKE
THIS, DOES IT MATTER IN A
CRIMINAL TRIAL YOU HAVE EVERY
RIGHT, EVERY AMERICAN CITIZEN,
WHETHER RICH OR POOR, HAS THE
RIGHT TO INVOKE THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT.
SHE MADE THE NOTE THAT DONALD
TRUMP REPEATEDLY TOOK THE FIFTH
IN HIS DEPOSITION.
IS THAT A DIFFERENT CONTEXT IN A
CIVIL SETTING?
>> YOU STILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO
INVOKE IT.
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE CIVIL
SETTING, WHEN YOU CAN INVOKE IT,
THE FACT FINDER OR JURY CAN DRAW
AN ADVERSE INFERENCE AGAINST
YOU.
SO IT'S INTERESTING THE TIMING
OF WHO INVOKED IT WHEN.
EARLY ON PEOPLE DID INVOKE IT A
LOT.
AND THEN I BELIEVE TWO OF THE
CHILDREN, INCLUDING IVANKA, DID
NOT INVOKE IT.
BUT THE MAIN DIFFERENCE IS YOU
CAN DRAW AN ADVERSE INFERENCE IN
CIVIL ACTIONS BUT IN CRIMINAL
CASES YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> AND IF YOU LISTEN TO HER,
DANA BASH, IF YOU LISTEN TO
LETITIA JAMES, IT'S THE TRUMP
FAMILY BUT SHE WAS DESCRIBING AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
ORGANIZED CRIME FAMILY.
THAT HE DIRECTED ALL OF THIS, HE
MET WITH MR. WEISSELBERG TO SIGN
OFF AND REVIEW THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS BUT HIS CHILDREN, TWO
SONS AND A DAUGHTER WERE ALL
PART OF IT.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
YOU AND MAGGIE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THAT ALL OF THIS GOES TO
THE HEART OF WHO HE IS EVEN MORE
SO THAN HIS POLITICAL AMBITIONS,
HIS POLITICAL HISTORY.
HAVING SAID THAT, THE WAY THAT
LETITIA JAMES DESCRIBED THE
ALLEGED MISCONDUCT IS VERY MUCH
IN KEEPING WITH AND INTENDED TO,
I THINK, BREAK THE SPELL OF WHO
HIS SUPPORTERS BELIEVE HE IS.
SHE SAID THAT THIS IS PROOF THAT
THERE SHOULDN'T BE TWO KINDS OF
JUSTICE.
AMERICA BASICALLY, ONE FOR THE
ELITE AN ONE FOR EVERYDAY
AMERICANS.
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO -- THE
WORD SHE USED WERE SCHEME AND
CONSPIRACY, BUILD THOSE THINGS
IN ORDER TO GET AWAY WITH THINGS
LIKE THE ELITE DO.
HIS WHOLE POLITICAL CAMPAIGN,
HIS WHOLE PRESIDENCY AND WE
EXPECT LIKELY 2024 WILL BE I'M
FOR THE LITTLE GUY.
AND THEY LOOK AT HIM AS SOMEBODY
WHO PLAYS IN THE ELITE POND BUT
ACTUALLY IS MORE FOR THE WORKER.
THIS, THE LANGUAGE THAT SHE USED
TO DESCRIBE THIS 250-PAGE LEGAL
DOCUMENT WAS CLEARLY INTENDED TO
DISRUPT THAT.
I MEAN UNCLEAR IF SHE CAN, BUT
IT WAS VERY NOTEWORTHY HOW SHE
DECIDED TO EXPLAIN IT.
>> AND YOU HAVE COVERED TRUMP
FOR A LONG TIME, JEREMY.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS AS A
STATEMENT FROM ONE OF TRUMP'S
ATTORNEYS AND DONALD TRUMP JR.
IS ECHOING THESE POINTS.
TODAY'S FIND IS ONLY ADVANCING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S POLITICAL
AGENDA.
THIS IS A FAMILIAR PLAYBOOK FROM
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
SAY IT'S ALL POLITICAL, IT'S ALL
DEMOCRATS OUT TO GET HIM, NOT
ADDRESSING THE FACTS.
>> YEAH, IT WAS TO BE EXPECTED,
RIGHT?
AND I THINK DANA'S POINT IS SPOT
ON.
WHEN I THINK BACK TO TRUMP IN
2016 AND 2020 AS WELL, HE WOULD
POINT OUT HE KNEW PEOPLE LIKE
HIM AND WEALTHY PEOPLE PLAYED BY
A DIFFERENT SET OF RULES.
DURING HIS PRESIDENCY HE DID
NOTHING TO TRY TO ADDRESS
DIFFERENCES IN TAXES, FOR
EXAMPLE, SOME OF THE LOOPHOLES
THAT HE VOWED TO CLOSE THAT HE
NEVER ACTUALLY ACTED ON.
HERE IT'S JUST REVEALING THAT
DONALD TRUMP NOT ONLY KNEW ABOUT
THIS SEPARATE SET OF RULES BUT
THAT HE ALSO PLAYED BY THAT
SEPARATE SET OF RULES.
AND THAT IS ULTIMATELY THE STORY
OF DONALD TRUMP'S RISE IN
BUSINESS AND IN POLITICS IS
CONSTANTLY PLAYING BY A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES.
WE ARE SEEING HERE TEN YEARS OF
INFLATION AND FALSE STATEMENTS
OF THE VALUATIONS OF THESE
PROPERTIES, BUT IT IS ONLY NOW,
ONLY NOW THAT TRUMP IS FINALLY
PERHAPS GETTING INVESTIGATED,
PERHAPS THERE IS GOING TO BE A
MEASURE OF JUSTICE FOR PLAYING
BY A DIFFERENT SET OF RULES.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER
OF INVESTIGATIONS THAT TRUMP
FACES, ALL OF THEM GO TO THIS
VERY SAME IDEA, THAT DONALD
TRUMP FOR YEARS HAS THOUGHT HE
WAS ABOVE THE LAW, AND PERHAPS
HE IS FINALLY FACING IT.
>> IF YOU READ THROUGH THIS,
THERE'S A LOT OF DETAILED INSIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BUSINESS
AND THE NUMBERS USED BY THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION, STUFF HE HAS
TRIED TO KEEP OUT OF THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN QUITE SOME TIME.